- This is the part that
nobody talks about.
(chill music)
The key is to be happy with yourself.
("Looking For Yourself" by Shisimusic)
I mean that system you just
say you're business buddies.
Is business class good?
- Yeah.
- Thank you, man.
I'm proud of you.
See, people yelled at me for
Babin being not in first class.
Let Babin work for 40 fucking
years and put in the work.
Fucking Babin.
DRock sent me (mumbling).
You're so fucking fancy.
Like, I have no interest
in making you happy
about my work/life balance.
You worry about your work/life balance.
My key is first me, and this is in order,
then my kids and my wife.
Because if I'm happy then
I can do anything for them,
and that's it.
- Right.
- And that's what matters.
(mellow music)
Going hard on my Indian content.
Did you hear about the dubbing?
You missed it, we were looking for you.
You were in a meeting.
(unintelligible mumbling)
It's crazy.
VaynerMentor is going to be a beast.
You know how exciting that's gonna be?
Like getting the email
and somebody's like,
"I made $100,000, I made four million."
(mellow music)
- On a day like today--
- Exponential?
- No, on a day like today
where the wifi sucks
and I can't get anything done
and you're traveling eight hours,
that hour with him is worth
a week's worth of work.
You know what I mean?
The difference between getting a lot done
and getting something
more meaningful done.
How much just proportionally
the latter matters.
That's such a, because when
I was younger I would stress.
Like man, I got nothing done today.
One meeting.
But that one meeting
is worth those 10 hours
of executional work times 100.
- What experience teaches you is that.
- It's that.
You know it's funny, as I get older,
I'm getting more patient in a way.
Because I went through that in my,
since I've known you business,
in that early mid-30s,
I was like patient because
I learned in those 12 years.
- Yeah.
- Impact.
(mellow music)
Productive.
One meeting that mattered.
Sometimes that's all it takes.
Why I didn't go to the
bathroom on the train?
Makes no sense.
This is the part that nobody talks about.
Friday, 8:15PM,
not going anywhere glamorous.
Six hours of travel.
For one meeting.
(unintelligible chatter)
Even when you're at the top of
your game, this is the worst.
Learning how to swim,
which will make that plunge
into opportunity, positivity, optimism.
Just reviewing some content.
Shit starts changing.
One single piece.
Because I have the luxury, I'm grateful.
I always feel guilty that I have
an amazing mother and father,
an amazing situation of
starting with nothing.
That gives me the optimism
and the perspective of positivity
that is needed to be successful in life.
And so, my Friday feeling
is that I'm desperate.
I'm desperate to penetrate you.
(laughing)
I'm just so desperate.
I never posted that on Instagram?
I thought I did.
(chill music)